(dramatic music)
- When my tics come on, I don't
really have a defense against it.
(clears throat)
And sometimes it just sort of comes out
in these explosive, spontaneous ways.
I'm an actor with Tourette's.
For a long time, I did
worry about exposing that
'cause I thought it would affect
getting hired, and auditions,
whatever it might be.
Now, I just put it on the table.
(clears throat).
It feels great to own it.
Huh.
My show is about having
Tourette's Syndrome
and finding my own way with it.
Tourette's Syndrome is
a neurological disorder
that you're born with.
The stereotype about Tourette's
is that people will curse
uncontrollably, which people do.
I've never done that.
When I tic, I clear my
throat (clears throat),
I cough (clears throat), sometimes
I make noises in my throat.
Huh.
So (clearing throat).
You're welcome to use that if you want.
(dramatic music)
Yeah, riding the subway is rough.
I still get nervous about it,
especially since I have this
throat-clearing, sniffing tic.
(clears throat)
I have Tourette's Syndrome.
That's why I'm makin' that noise.
I can't help it.
When I'm acting, I don't tic.
I remember.
Somehow, I'm like, in this zone,
and I'm able to just focus.
It kind of just, like, goes away,
and it says, okay, take a
break, do what you love,
and I'll be waitin' for
ya when ya come back.
(dramatic music)